Hi everybody.
Thanks for joining us on your midday break.
Um,
this is one of the very last events we're doing for the in the company of women
book tour.
And I have to say these conversations have been some of the most meaningful I've
had in the last 12 years of running my business.
And I run a blog called design sponge for the past 12 years,
which has slowly over the past decade kind of evolved from a site where we talk
about beautiful things to talking about the people behind those things and the
struggles they face and life and work.
And the new book in the company of women is,
is all about highlighting women's stories,
their struggles,
how they've pushed through difficult times.
All of these incredible women are a part of the book.
And today we're going to be talking about some of their stories and their
experiences.
So I'm going to let them introduce themselves.
Let's go down this way.
I'm Claire Manzur,
I'm one of the Co founders of a company called [inaudible] and we sell the
pieces and tell the stories of emerging makers in the United States.
And recently we've also expanded to include,
um,
just discoveries across lifestyle categories,
everything from our favorite restaurants to apps to,
um,
books.
And we do that in our podcasts and our newsletter and on the website.
Um,
I'm,
Eric has to reload the other cofounder of,
of a kind and cleared,
did such a great job.
I have nothing else.
Sorry.
Erica,
would you like to introduce me?
I know
I'm,
I'm Karen Karen Young.
I am the founder of a company called we shave.
It's a women's,
uh,
shave shave brand,
um,
and subscription club for,
well obviously for women.
Okay.
Um,
so we're going to start with one of my favorite questions from the book,
which has to do with looking way,
way,
way back in time.
So I would love to know from each of you what you wanted to be when you were
little and how that connects to what you do now in any way.
Karen,
let's start with you.
Um,
so when I was younger,
I,
I had this fantasy of being a lawyer and I apologize now,
but,
um,
no,
I had this fantasy of being a lawyer.
I tend to be very analytical and I love to sort of process and really sort of
pick things apart.
Um,
so when I was young,
obviously it was the fantasy of like,
yeah,
I'm going to be in like this great high rise building and you know,
it's going to overlook the,
you know,
the Brooklyn Waterfront.
And eventually I was like,
actually I think somewhere hidden in there is designed because it was like
everything that I fantasize about was this concept of what a lawyer,
you know,
would look like and what my life would look like and so on.
Um,
and later on I just,
I kind of,
I actually went to school for psychology and I realized that I really just love
just,
you know,
pulling things apart and like really analyzing things and so on.
Um,
and I think the way that I turned it into what I do now,
I realized that I had a real love for product design.
Um,
and I also had a love for sort of understanding how people use things,
how to make people happy,
you know,
how like a daily experience,
um,
can sort of be changed into something that actually,
you know,
leaves a mark on someone.
Um,
so anytime I touch product or looked at product,
I always kind of thought about all of those little things.
Um,
and now what I do,
you know,
a good portion of what I do,
I hear from women a lot who are like,
you know,
email and say,
this product has really changed my life,
or,
you know,
the center.
So amazing.
Um,
and so somehow I think,
I,
I like to say I took the scenic route to where I am now.
Um,
but somehow I think I managed to pull all those things together into a really
fantastic career.
[inaudible]
Erica,
what about you too?
Um,
when I was growing up,
I don't think I knew what I wanted to be,
or at least,
um,
was unwilling to commit to an idea of what I wanted to be.
And when I was in college,
I did this amazing program called roadtrip nation that involved driving across
the country in an RV with two friends and interviewing people who had taken an
interesting career paths.
And one of the people that we interviewed was a tune is a Rubenstein who was
then the editor and chief of 17 magazine.
And I had booked that interview and it was someone I was really excited about
and we were asking the people,
we interviewed all sorts of career questions.
And I said that I didn't know what I wanted to be.
And she was like,
you do though?
And it was like,
oh,
that's going to be one of these things like she,
whatever.
I'm just like,
not going to get out of this what I want to get out of this.
And I was like,
well,
I love magazines,
but I just like,
don't know if that's the thing for me.
Um,
and she's like,
okay,
so tell me about this.
And we started talking about the magazines that I had right when I was growing
up.
And I was like,
wow,
you know,
like all the teen magazines.
But also Disney Adventures and consumer reports for kids.
And she was like,
that's not normal.
Not Normal.
If you read those magazines,
that mean means you really like magazines,
you should do this.
Um,
and so I did,
um,
and I worked in magazines for five years before we started other kind.
And then I think it became clear to me that that world wasn't what I wanted it
to be anymore.
But the idea of creating content and engaging people with storytelling invoice,
um,
and uh,
tying it all together with these products that we sell is what was meaningful to
me.
Um,
you know,
I think I was also unwilling to commit to,
to my many interests.
And when you asked this question for the bucket,
I had this like moment of clarity where I remembered for really long time saying
when people would ask me what I wanted to be when it was like really young,
I would be like,
well,
I'm going to be an ice skater and a singer and a dancer.
And mostly because it was like,
well,
I want to be a pop star,
but I really like ice skating lessons too.
And I distinctly remember like my parents never once being like,
it's going to be hard to do all three,
like pick a lane.
And I look back and I'm like,
that definitely I remembered their reaction to that and being like,
well,
if they didn't say I couldn't,
I can definitely do this.
Like it's realistic because I kind of,
you know,
you expect someone to shoot you down when you say that.
And I actually think that that sort of like style of parenting and just being
like,
sure you can totally do that is kind of what led me to this place now where
we're know always coming up with this big ideas and being like,
why not let's do it.
Let's try this and let's start a business.
All of which seemed kind of unrealistic when you know,
when they're just an idea.
Um,
and so I,
I,
I will credit my parents with sort of being like,
sure,
yeah,
you can do that because what's the point of saying like you can't,
I'm so happy.
You mentioned wanting to be an ice dance.
One of the most frequent answer is given for that question.
And this book was something that had to do with performance,
whether it was a dancer or a singer or an actress.
And I found it so interesting because not only did most people not end up doing
those things,
but I found that people who run their own businesses of any type you have to
perform that is a huge part of what your daily job will be,
is being the face of your business.
And so I thought it was fascinating that all of these careers found a way back
into that aspect of performance.
Um,
but you,
you all brought up something that makes me think about the idea of mentorship
and visibility and visibility was a huge inspiration for this book.
And I thought a lot about how women not having role models or very visible
examples of people in their field or in fields they maybe don't even know about
yet.
How that can affect their desire to be in that field or even their knowledge of
it at all.
Did any of you have mentors in your current field that you looked up to,
um,
or anybody maybe in a different field that inspired you to maybe dream a little
bigger or try your own project?
Um,
we were really inspired by 20 by 200,
which is a company started by Jen Beckman that has a similar model to ours with
prints.
And I remember,
uh,
she would,
one of the things that she did is she had,
she had a tumbler for 20 by 200,
but she also had a tumbler that was like Jen at 20 by 200.
And she would talk a lot about the goings on behind the business.
And I read it obsessively and I remember when they raised venture capital and I
remember and like how she talked about that and thinking like,
what does this mean for that business?
And really following that closely.
And I think that that certainly gave me a sense that like this can be done and
this is kind of how it's done and one person can do this and take this,
make an idea into a reality.
Cool.
Um,
so I think that for me,
what I did is I kind of started,
I started by like reading magazines and books and blogs and so on.
And then I'm,
I'm a little bit on the Shyer side,
normally a very much an introvert.
Um,
so I started doing is,
you know,
I would,
I started forming a little bit of a community within the blogging world
especially,
and I would just kind of reach out and go to like events and so on.
And people that I admired,
you know,
people who,
uh,
many of them actually are in the book.
Um,
I ended up just kind of getting to know them on,
on less of a mentorship level at first and more of a,
I'm really curious about you and curious about what you do.
Um,
and from there,
you know,
they became mentors to me and some even friends.
Yeah.
I love that you brought up,
because
that was probably the only thread connecting all of these women and the book was
the importance of community and how the lack of it sometimes even stymied the
creation of a business because there wasn't that sort of strong base and support
system to keep encouraging you through those tough times.
And I'd love to talk a little bit about the way community affects each of your,
your business lives.
Because for me,
I know if I didn't have other women that talk to who ran businesses of any kind,
I don't know if I would've gotten done when I've gotten done so far because I
think those were the people who reminded me that everyone's going to face
hurdles.
Everyone's going to have tough times.
You're going to have moments where your business gets set back a little bit.
But you'll be able to push forward.
Who were those people for you and how did you find and build the community you
have?
I think it took us a little while to find those people for sure.
And I think in the beginning we definitely felt like we didn't know that many
other women who were running their own businesses and building up a group of
designers.
It'd be,
we're working with,
definitely helped with that.
And I think the ones that we are,
the more that we have this,
like the closest relationship with in this way are,
um,
Lizzy and Katheryn Fortunato the sisters behind the line.
Um,
Lizzy Fortunato and we'll have these like four hour long dinners that where
everybody is like sort of shouting over each other and we talk about everything
from hiring and firing to like managing resources to,
um,
design and aesthetic things like who makes your shoes?
Karen,
what about you?
Well,
first I'm inviting myself.
I appreciate it.
Thank you.
Um,
so it,
it kind of does,
you know,
um,
jumps off from my last answer,
which is where,
you know,
I really did just start creating this,
um,
an honest community around me.
And,
and what you said just now was really important and just,
you know,
people who were actually talking about the struggles of running a business.
I needed to have that truth because what I noticed with businesses that there's
a lot of gloss and glitter over it,
you know,
um,
my boyfriend somewhere hanging out over there somewhere.
Um,
oh,
he likes to call it.
Um,
Lisa can,
you know,
you really like to read a lot of design porn,
like a lot of business board and you know,
and I'm just like,
ugh.
You know,
I'm eating like those entrepreneur magazine articles and ink.com articles and
they're like,
this company made $500 million in the first two months of business and your
lung,
it's only the stats people want to share.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
And they're like,
but you forgot to mention the part where they were like crying in the closet,
you know?
But,
um,
yeah.
So it was really,
really,
really important to me to be surrounded by those women who were very,
very honest about the struggles or even the good things about what it took to,
to run,
um,
and grow a business.
And what I found was I approached those women even kind of thinking that they
were going to be like,
oh yeah,
you know,
this happened for me overnight.
And then they were like,
girl,
no,
sit down,
let's talk.
And I mean we have been in the same position a lot where we have tried to be
really honest and it's always surprising to me how surprised people are.
And you know,
you don't brag about it publicly how shitty times are and we don't.
And it's just not good for your business,
right.
To be like,
oh,
it's actually awful right now we're about to fall through.
But I find that like in the moments where it's good and it's safe to sort of
like speak in retrospect to the times that had been really hard,
it's really therapeutic to talk about it yourself too and just be like,
right.
Because this is going to happen again and like acknowledging that it changes and
it gets better.
It makes such a difference.
And for us a turning point was when we sold the business and you know,
you have a sense of security and I feel like that's when we really let loose to
everybody who came was like congratulations and we were like,
you want to hear what it was like before?
Like we were pretty sure that we were going to have to close the doors at many
points over the last five years.
Um,
I think it's really important to be honest about those things when you can be,
yeah,
more of that please.
Yeah,
and I think we've also,
there is the fact that we've been around for six years and have followed this
sort of business cycles and seeing the highs and lows and seen the company that
everybody's like so excited about,
you know,
raving about and can't wait to pour their money into then crash and burn a year
later or whatever.
Seeing enough of those things happen.
You,
you become a little bit like desensitized to those stories.
Usually.
If it seems too good to be true.
It is.
Yeah.
Now that's been my general experience as well.
I think too often people do make articles,
books,
anything TV segments about businesses feel like a highlight reel and it is this
moment of this much venture capital money,
you know this huge staff,
the success,
boom,
everyone has a fancy house.
I'm like five nannies and everything's great and that's generally not the way
things work out.
But people are intimidated and scared to talk about these things publicly.
And that's one of the reasons I wanted to make this book was to create a safe
space to have these conversations.
And so one of the things I asked everybody in the book as you all know,
is to share a moment when something didn't work out,
whether that was a mistake or a thing,
a time you had to like take a step back or slow down and what you learned from
that.
Because I think that mistakes and failures are all just very much opportunities
that are disguise and chances to learn things and they are more painful than
when you learn things from great opportunities.
But they're important to,
to pay attention to.
So I'd love to know from each of you an example of a time when something did not
go well,
but what you were able to pull out of that moment.
I mean,
the one that comes to mind most immediately,
um,
is a time when we pursued an expansion of the business that didn't feel like
what Eric,
her I wanted to do,
but it felt like the only way to grow the business aggressively and the only way
to convince investors to give us money.
And we even said to each other at the time we turned each other,
we'd be like,
you also think it sounds miserable to build this thing,
right?
And be like,
totally like hire people to run the part of business.
We won't have to touch it.
Right?
Yeah.
Like we totally got checked more.
Like,
you also think this sounds miserable.
Totally.
Okay,
let's go in this room and tell these people we're going to do it and it's gonna
make us like $1 billion.
And we got enough money to start expanding the business.
And that way it was like a marketplace model and it didn't work out and it
almost killed the business and we really like,
you know we had,
you know these sort of like 11th hour things come through and save us from
having to close the doors.
But we really thought it was going to be the thing that was going to end of a
kind.
And I looked back and I was like let's never do anything again.
It's not the thing that we're really passionate or excited about.
Let's not do it just because it's the thing that seems like the trajectory we're
supposed to be on because we're a startup and because we should be able to
demonstrate hockey stick growth and how we're going to scale and no one will
give us money if we don't want this hockey stick growth.
So it's like you,
you start growing slowly and then you get investment and then it shoots right up
to the sky.
Yeah.
Because that's when all your graphs are supposed to look like cause that's all
your protection.
That is
certainly,
it wasn't hard to be that hockey,
but that's like what all the venture capitalists want to see.
When you put up projections,
they'll put $2 million in and then it'll look like that.
Yeah,
that's realistic.
Very realistic.
And we did it and you know,
we pursued this thing that didn't sound fun to us.
It just sounded like the thing that was what we should be doing in order to grow
a lot.
And it ultimately,
it was just as much of a nightmare as we thought and we weren't good at it.
And I think like Eric and I are no ourselves also well enough to know that.
Like if we're not excited about it,
if we're not invested in it,
it's,
we're not going to do a good job at it.
So Karen,
what about you?
Uh,
so you guys are describing exactly where I am right now,
which is so creepy,
can stop you from doing that.
Don't build a market.
Um,
so we should have is actually my second business.
My first business,
um,
was in the textile design space.
And,
um,
I really just went out there and this is the type of person that I am anyway,
like if you give me a piece of furniture from Ikea and you put the,
you know,
the,
the sort of instructions next to it,
I'm going to chuck the introductions and be like,
ah,
like,
you know,
and that were like an upside down table or something.
Um,
because I just love sort of figuring it out.
And that's what I did with my first business.
I figured it out.
Um,
but I had no idea how to ask for help.
I didn't know who to turn to to ask for help.
Um,
and I,
I basically was like,
okay,
I see this business,
which is like 10 times bigger than me doing exactly these things.
So I'm going to model that.
I mean,
while they're here and I'm here and I tried to model exactly what they were
doing,
you know,
they had staff and money and everything,
like all the stuff that I didn't have.
Um,
and I basically tried to,
to build a business like that,
like all by my onesie and completely floundered.
Um,
and so I actually had to take some time off.
I took time off and I pause and I went back for a full time job.
Um,
and I learned and I ate,
what did they call it as a cro pie.
Yeah.
My a South American inflections are coming out.
Um,
yeah.
And,
and so that for me was a really,
really,
really humbling moment.
And so I'm,
I'm back now building my second business and um,
you know,
it's falling in line of the startups.
So now I've got a little bit of that gloss on me and you know,
some venture capital or like kind of knocking and I'm like,
okay,
you know,
like how,
how do I do this now better than I did the first time around.
And the difference between now and then is that I know that I'm emailing you,
girls are one thing,
we're going to have dinner.
Um,
and I have help.
I finally accepted that I need help.
I need tools in the book.
Part of when I was talking a little bit about being in that position of sort of
floundering with the company.
You know,
I described it as if someone had sort of like built a glass mountain and they
had told everyone else how to climate and like giving them,
you know,
all the fancy shoes and clips and everything and here I was like trying to like
build this stuff and climbed the mountain at the same time.
Um,
so yeah,
the,
the difference now is,
is having people around me and,
and reaching out for help when they need it.
It makes a big difference to have help.
And it also,
it makes it a difference to have people who can help remind you to listen to
your gut.
I think almost every problem that I discussed interviewing people for this book
really involved,
somebody's ignoring their gut for a second and saying,
but this is what I think I should be doing.
And I think modeling yourself and another business.
I did the same thing with my blog and rented a,
and we got a three year lease for a studio years ago because I thought,
well,
every other blog has a fancy studio with like adorable girls lined up at pink
desk.
So I should have the exact same thing and signed myself up for like a ridiculous
amount of money to spend.
And that after three months my employees were like,
oh,
I don't want to work here anymore.
We all can.
We just work from home.
Like that was much easier.
It's cold outside.
I don't want to walk here and,
but I had signed myself up for three years of rent and that was an embarrassing
mistake to make 10 years into running a business where I thought shit.
And I know better than to make decisions based on what I think it's something
should be.
But that's something that I think plagues women in particular a lot as the sort
of comparison game.
How do you guys pull yourselves out of that when you feel those moments of like,
Ooh,
but this company does this?
So I should do that.
I mean,
I think one thing that's helped me is seeing so many companies where I felt
like,
oh my God,
if only like we had that level of success and seeing their dumb falter in some
way or in some cases even fail.
And I just think it's years and years of that.
I mean,
I still don't always know when,
I still don't always know to pull myself out of that,
but I do think we're like almost seven years into this and there's just been so
many,
every single company that I've ever sat in idolize and been like,
why aren't we more like them?
I've now seen the cracks at one point or another.
I think yeah,
that helps.
Yeah.
To read very quickly is like,
no,
you know,
um,
I,
I think that it's just of built into this sense of success and failure,
you know,
that we have,
and this as humanity.
It's,
it's,
it's sort of part of,
it's kind of like looking in a mirror,
you know what I mean?
Except you're the person who determines what that mirror is every day.
Like,
what is it that I want to model?
What does it do?
I,
you know,
do I want to achieve and so on.
Um,
and so when you find your tribe,
I think it's very natural to kind of go,
hey,
you know,
she's just like me,
but yet she's got all this going on,
you know,
like,
what am I doing wrong?
Um,
so it's just become really important for me to just gut check,
you know,
like you said,
and remember,
well,
even if they're,
they're here now,
you know,
maybe they were in my position a few years back or,
or whatever it is.
Or even just call up my friends.
You know,
like I said in the book,
um,
one of my friends is like,
no,
Karen,
it takes 10 years to become an overnight success.
I'm like,
all right,
just seven to go.
Well,
let's talk about success.
Um,
this has been probably the most interesting topic I've discussed on the book
tour because I find it tends to be a very emotional one.
One that's tied into our ideas of who's come before us,
who comes after us,
our families.
Um,
what does success mean to each of you right now?
And is that something that has changed as you and your business have evolved?
Karen,
let's start with you.
So success to me right now is so much simpler than the girl who was like,
you know,
thought I was going to be a lawyer in like,
dolce Gabbana like head to toe with,
you know,
the penthouse overlooking the river.
Um,
I just left my full time job.
I was able to grow my business enough that I could take that leap.
Um,
there's some fantastic things coming down the line.
I got up every morning at about five o'clock in the morning.
I worked on my business before I went to work.
I worked a nine to five.
I came home and worked on it a little bit later.
Um,
you know,
until the evening is as much as I could stay up.
Um,
and after two years of doing that,
I was able to finally leave and take the leap and from me right now,
success is,
I mean I get up and it's like I'm seeing things,
you know,
in a,
in a whole different light,
like I'm actually able to watch the leaves change color and I'm able to go to
the gym at 12 o'clock in the afternoon if I feel like it.
And it's so simple,
but it's the sweetest feeling that I've ever felt in my life.
Um,
so success is,
you know,
having the time to travel,
to kind of be in charge of my day a little bit,
to be overwhelmed if that's,
if that's what it is,
you know?
Um,
yeah,
to have dinner with friends.
It's really,
really simple right now and very sweet.
What about you Claire?
Naca?
Um,
I think,
you know what you're saying about sort of having,
having the autonomy over your day.
I think being able to,
you know,
control as much as anybody can control anything,
um,
their day to day
and make decisions about how they want to live their lives.
Um,
that,
that is success for me,
that that is so important to me.
And it wasn't something I realized until we sold our business.
And now,
you know,
we have a parent company like tech know,
like boss and overload and the wonderful thing about it and the reason it's
worked as they've given us an incredible amount of independence and autonomy and
that all of a sudden brought into very sharp focus.
The one most important thing to me about my job,
which is that like feeling like I'm deciding,
you know,
what my day looks like and you know what time it unified could go to the gym in
the morning so I can get in a little later and all.
Um,
and you know,
what projects I'm prioritizing and stuff like that.
It really,
I hadn't been aware of it,
of how important it was to me before then.
Um,
but now,
now it really is.
I think the other thing too that has changed for me in the last,
and I don't think this is what defines success,
but making money has become a much bigger priority for me.
I think I've,
you know what,
I've just gotten older and you know,
I like got married and you start to think about your future.
But I think I've also just noticed,
um,
over the last six,
seven years,
how much personal wealth gives you the privilege of,
um,
expanding personal wealth for others and putting in,
you know,
just expanding through your networks,
both,
um,
access and growth and privilege.
And I've really noticed the ways that it tends to be sequestered to male
networks.
And I think the more women amass personal wealth,
the more they amass power and influence.
And I think that's really important.
And I also just think,
you know,
obviously like money makes your life easier.
And I just never used to think about it that way.
And I think it tends not to be like a very,
um,
uh,
very phone and quality to think about like,
I really want to get rich,
but I,
I'm like really getting comfortable with that idea and just saying that like,
yeah,
I want to make a lot of money.
It's important to them.
There is very clearly a double standard even among women about profitability,
about wealth and about how we discussed those things because I have watched
bloggers and my community and other makers sort of go from being,
you know,
tiny indie companies to being huge brands and watching people like cheer them
on.
And then there's that tipping point where you can tell,
or at least it seems like from the outside they are now financially successful
and then people start to turn and be like,
Oh,
who does she think she has?
Like she has a nanny now and she has authentic anymore.
Like,
no,
she's authentic to who she like this is the path.
Exactly.
Career.
Yeah.
And I don't think it's to say that for financial and yeah.
And I don't think the financial success is the only measure of success,
but I think it is one that often comes with a lot of guilt and a lot of
pressure,
um,
from within the community as a female makers and entrepreneurs.
And it's one that I think should be discussed a little bit more.
Well,
even just the thing you said about having a nanny,
I mean,
I want kids,
but I'm really intimidated by the idea because I really love working.
Right?
But if I work and I make enough money where I can have support in somebody's
helping me raise my kids,
I can do both.
And like that to me is one of the reasons to make sure that I'm amassing
personal well so that I can do that.
And then I can do both.
And yeah,
I just,
I,
you know,
I think that,
I led
with that idea of like,
I think it's important so that women can spread it to other networks because
there just aren't enough women investors and things like that.
And I do think that is important.
But I also don't think women should apologize for wanting to have money just for
the sake of making life easier.
No,
not at all.
I'd love to know from each of you,
what is one thing you wish you had known before becoming an entrepreneur?
I'll start with mine,
which is I wish,
I wish and I constantly think about this.
I wish I had known.
I wish someone had told me you will never stop making mistakes.
There's not a single person 40 50 years into their company that is not still
currently making mistakes.
Um,
but I think the silver lining of the fact that these mistakes and hurdles never
stopped is that they become infinitely more fulfilling to solve and learn from.
And I think when you're in your 20s and starting a business,
it's just,
Oh my God,
can I get through it?
Can I make payroll this week?
Like,
can we pay our taxes on time?
And now that I'm in my thirties and inching closer to 40,
I feel like I am looking for these lessons in a way that just makes the hurdles
a little bit less terrifying.
But I think I thought if I worked hard enough,
they would disappear altogether.
It's kind of like that thing where I think high schoolers,
like I'm guessing a lot of you in this room probably wear those high schoolers
where you felt like if you just like took all the AP classes and just got
straight A's,
like life would be a piece of cake.
That doesn't happen stock,
it does not happen.
It just gets harder and more complicated.
So I wish someone had like drilled that in a little earlier.
It's just a good reminder because I think I still think that you're just going
to get so good one day,
then I'll just like be able to make all the right decisions and those will be a
breeze.
I think the problem with that,
and I had the same realization,
is that that it seems everything else stays the same.
Like as if we're all working in operating in a vacuum and that like markets
don't change.
Internet doesn't change people's assumptions and desires for products and things
change and there's just so much that's out of our control and that you don't
change.
Yeah.
Yeah,
exactly.
Oh No,
I'm in,
for those of us,
I mean I was 23 when I started my business and I'm 35 now.
And those are drastically different places in life.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I wish that,
um,
I kind of always was fixated on the end of the road.
I wish that someone had told me that I was going to spend a lot of time on the
damn road.
It's like,
it's a long,
long,
long journey.
You know,
I think the end changes,
um,
for each of us as we grow and,
and different things sort of take,
you know,
are become more important.
Um,
so yeah,
you know,
similar to what you're saying,
like kind of as you go along and you,
you know,
you make mistakes.
It's like,
I feel like I'm,
you know,
on the road that I get to the sign post and it's like,
you got it.
You did it.
Yeah.
You know,
and then it's like,
all right,
you get to the next one.
And it's a whole other set of lessons to learn,
you know,
especially for me,
I think the greatest thing is in scaling a business and figuring out how in the
world to to do that.
Um,
every time I make it to one milestone and kind of like,
all right,
I've got everything in my pocket now,
I'm just going to go and apply that to the next one.
No,
that's not gonna work.
Yeah.
I think for me,
I'm hearing you're only
going to spend 20% of your time doing things that are your core competencies.
Um,
I mean I came from working in magazines and I was an editor and I spent the bulk
of my time working in magazines as an editor editing.
Um,
and you know,
I worked on other little things here and there,
but the core,
my core job was editing and that's what I did every single day.
And even when I was producing all of the content for the site or editing all of
the content for all the kind,
I still was only spending really 20% of my time on that because there's just so
many other things you have to do.
And we've had to get good at managing lawyers and accountants,
um,
and thinking about Facebook marketing strategies and creating newsletter
templates and all of these things.
Managing Web developers that,
you know,
of course we're part of the business,
but that we are still very,
very involved in.
Well,
before we opened it up to everybody for questions,
I want to ask you a quick lightening round of short,
not to be over-thought questions.
So let's start with one that you've all already answered before.
That should be easy.
What is a tool object or a ritual that you could not live without in your work
day?
Let's start with you.
I run every morning and they can't,
I'm crazy without it.
Um,
I'm,
I'm a serious to do list maker.
Karen.
I drink like 12 cups of tea.
Um,
if you weren't doing the job that you're doing right now,
what other job would you like to try?
Karen,
let's try it with you.
Uh,
so I have a degree in psychology and seeing how even that has has been affected
by technology.
I would go back and figure out how I could make a mental wellness available to
more people for less money.
That's great.
I would do something around content for teenagers.
I don't know.
I think I would probably like create things like with my hands,
he'd be a maker and you could sell your own thing.
You're very good at it.
Um,
what's one piece of advice you would give to a young woman who was hoping to
start her business right now?
Something really basic and simple.
Tell people
that you want to start a business.
Yeah.
Dealt,
like,
tell people,
be like,
make yourself accountable to someone.
Say I want to do this thing.
And I think the more people you tell,
they're like,
oh,
I have a friend who actually builds websites.
You should talk to him or
whatever.
Yeah.
Okay.
Uh,
I'm speaking to,
I'm going to be selfish and speak to my own inner 15 year old right now.
And that is,
um,
get help.
Reach out to anyone.
Doesn't matter how big you think they are or who,
you know,
might not respond to your email.
Just try no that you're not going to be able to do everything and that's okay.
And you will find people who can help you to do the things you don't know how to
do.
This is a two parter.
Um,
what is the hardest part of your job and what is also your favorite part of your
job?
Sometimes they're the same thing.
Yeah,
I mean,
I would say managing other people is probably the hardest part of my job and
it's definitely sometimes the most rewarding.
I mean,
ultimately the most rewarding thing for me is always like working on coming up
with an idea and seeing thing become like a physical product product.
Um,
it's really rewarding.
Yeah.
Those are mine to managing people I think is something that we are still really
struggling with in our team has always been really small.
Um,
and it means that there's not a lot of time for us to be both,
you know,
producing things on a day to day basis and managing.
Um,
and I really want to get better at it.
I think it's also hard because Eric and I worked really closely.
We know each other,
so I'll have such high expectations of ourselves and others and just have very
similar instincts.
Like sometimes,
you know,
it's like a melting and I,
and so it's very easy to get frustrated when people don't have those same
instincts,
which is totally unreasonable.
And that's what I don't know on a day to day basis.
And like,
you wouldn't screw up like that,
but like,
maybe that's just because like you,
like,
you know,
I just,
I don't know what the expectations of other people,
I don't know how upset together,
like,
yeah,
we're working on it.
Um,
for me it's being the final answer.
I feel like jeopardy all the time.
It's like,
you know,
the final answer is,
and I'm like,
shit,
that's me.
Okay,
I'll be right with you.
Um,
and then,
um,
I love getting to know my customers.
Um,
yeah,
it's,
it's really fun to talk to other women.
Yeah.
All right.
Last but not least,
what is your favorite thing to come home to after a very long day at work?
Okay.
Like a Sitcom and my husband's Kale Salad.
Maybe a glass of wine.
My bunny.
I have a bunny.
Yeah,
it's hard to get really upset when there's a bunny.
I'm going to win at Christmas and birthdays and everything for this one.
But that guy right there.
Um,
before I open it up to questions for anybody who has them in the audience,
I just want to thank postmen books for being here.
They have the book in the back if anybody wants a copy and thank you to Google
for having us.
So,
and thank you to these amazing women.
So
anybody have any questions for the panel or for any of us?
Oh yeah,
go for it.
Hi.
Thanks again for coming.
Um,
I had a question about learning and just growing as you go.
So one of the common threads in a lot of the questions was how you learned from
your own experiences or previous ones and from experiences of other people that
you talked to.
But what's your opinion on how to just grow either as a leader or get better at
managing people?
Would you suggest I meet your business school or books or you know,
what are your thoughts on that?
I think
everybody has different paths to that.
I'm somebody who never went to business school,
probably should have,
but I read,
I read a lot of business books,
but I think that being a leader is a muscle memory.
I think it's something that you have to do a lot of different times to kind of
feel comfortable thinking of yourself that way.
Um,
I started my business as like a sole proprietor and now have to oversee people
and that's still very uncomfortable for me.
But the more times I do it,
the more it becomes a muscle.
I feel more comfortable flexing and getting used to.
And I think one of the things I find most helpful is to maybe make a list of the
ways in which you are already leading in your life.
Whether that's like leading a team meeting or you're in charge of like a
volunteer project outside of work,
reminding yourself of the moments where you're already a leader and doing a good
job of it helps you feel more confident.
I think learning to ask for help but also,
or ask for feedback and help,
but knowing,
vetting that yourself and knowing what fits for you.
Um,
I remember the first time we had to let an employee go,
we called two of our advisers ask them for help who had more experience and who
had done this in the past.
And one of them was like,
well,
just what,
just tell her that,
um,
you are getting rid of the role.
And we're like,
well,
we're not basically,
yeah,
just tell her that and then you'll hire someone later and it'll be fine and
you'll just be a lot easier.
And that just didn't ring true to us.
And then we called another advisor and she was like,
helped us write a whole script that was like,
I'm sure you have.
I'm sure you know that this is coming.
We've had these conversations and just gave us sort of the strength to be like,
you can do this.
Um,
and that felt right to us.
so I think,
yeah,
just vetting advice too.
MMM.
So I don't manage that many people know.
But,
um,
in my previous job I managed about like 25 people or so.
Um,
and the,
the one thing that I learned,
especially within the corporate setting,
I learned that,
um,
a lot of people were sort of pretending to be managers based on what they
thought the role called for or what it meant to be a manager.
And I ended up having the best,
um,
the best conversations and the best relationships with the people that I managed
when I Kinda just sat down and let them speak to me,
you know,
um,
and just kind of got to the heart of what was going on with them and allowed
them to be human and have room to grow.
Um,
yeah.
Thanks.
Oh,
hi.
So over here,
uh,
so two of the topics that you all talked about where growth of your business but
also autonomy and control over your day.
And I'm wondering how to bring those two things together.
Can you do both at once?
Is it a one after the other situation?
I'm just wondering on your thoughts on that.
I do think,
um,
I remember when we were in I guess like year two or something of the business
and I just started dating my husband and I was like,
I'm really sorry I can't be in a relationship cause I stay up until like one 30
in the morning every night with my computer on my lap and being like,
there's no way it can do this.
And now it's,
that to me is like a marker because I look back on that and I'm like,
I go to bed at like 11 every night at the latest.
And I do think it gets easier over time.
And I think with most businesses,
you probably have to put a lot more in in the first like two to three years than
you do in the years that follow.
Um,
but I also think maybe,
I don't know if I gave a false impression of what autonomy means,
I still don't really feel like I have control over my day.
Like I still work all of the time and I work harder than I think most of my
friends do.
But it's knowing that it's my choice to do that and like when to do it.
Exactly.
That's really important.
Can say yes or no to the meeting.
Yeah,
exactly.
That's an important,
I think autonomy is something that sometimes gets conflated with like the idea
of like everyone is okay with the choices you made.
And I think that that's one of the hardest things,
and I might flick,
I talk about this with my wife Julia all the time,
is that like we were both freelancers with essentially kind of can control
everything we do in our life,
but no one talks to you about what it feels like to control other people's were
not controlled,
but to absorb other people's reactions to those choices.
Because most of us have the autonomy to say like,
nope,
not going to be on that call.
We're not going to be at that meeting,
which is fine and the world will go on and your business will go on.
But someone might be mad and that's,
I feel like women in particular have a difficult time with people being
disappointed or upset and that's where I think a support system or like just
friends to go get coffee with comes in handy where you can be like,
I felt so bad that I didn't go to that,
but I also felt really good that I stayed home and didn't go to that thing.
So it's like managing those feelings.
I think that like having a partnership has made that so much easier.
If just somebody else being like,
no,
it's okay that you didn't,
or like we're not going to do this and it's going to be fine.
And like,
and that has been such a huge one of the many values of having a partner.
Yeah.
I think part of it is also managing your own expectations of yourself and
whatever sort of guilt trips that you might put yourself through as well.
So,
you know,
there have been times when I'm like,
okay,
I really need to make this yoga yoga class at six o'clock for my own health,
like my own benefit.
Um,
so I'll get up really early tomorrow,
you know?
So you just,
it's,
it's about balancing your expectations of yourself too.
Yeah.
Thanks.
Hi.
So I have two questions,
one of which is for context purposes,
if you could,
oh.
Um,
let us know the size of your business currently.
And the second one is for someone who is sort of starting out with an idea for a
business.
Uh,
how would you recommend going about figuring out who to partner with or who to
bring on your team and how to find those people?
I'll start with my side.
Um,
I have three full time employees,
me being one of them.
Um,
and I have about a team of 10 to 12 writers who kind of kind of come in and out
of my blog life.
And then this book was made by three people basically,
so small.
We're six full time and then also have very interns.
Freelancers.
Yeah.
Um,
I am a team of one and I actually have some contract people who work with me.
I have a Clo and a marketing person and yeah.
But I just kind of fill people in around me like that for now.
Um,
what was the second part of your question?
Will you remind me?
The second question is how do you determine at the beginning stages who to
partner with if you should bring someone on to partner with you and how you find
those people?
Hmm.
My gut response to that would be to be very,
very cautious of taking on a partner.
If you don't absolutely need one because companies can grow really quickly and
then someone else has a lot of control over your company.
So like I,
I had cut my company like really,
really small and I got legal advice to like incorporate it and make it safer and
I'm the one hand that's good,
but it also means like a thing that feels like my baby is shared by other people
and that's a weird feeling.
So I would be really cautious and get a super,
super well vetted contract because I think sometimes the best friends can go
into business and then you know,
expectations or ideas of where a brand should go change.
So I always feel like write the contract with the worst possible outcome in mind
so that if that does happen,
there is a rubric to follow because that happens a lot.
Yeah.
I mean I think,
I can't imagine doing this without a partner,
but I also think we have a really specific relationship and really specific
partnership.
And um,
we have had known each other for years beforehand.
We had worked in like very small capacities with each other.
Um,
but in a way that I think shed light on what are our w are working tactics were
um,
and helped us sort of vet,
could we do this together?
Um,
but then,
you know,
logistically when we started the company,
our equity,
neither of our equity vested,
it all,
I was on a four year vesting schedule.
We,
you know,
we're in this place with a one year cliff,
meaning that neither of us had equity until after the first year.
So that it does give you that chance to say,
is this actually gonna work for us?
Okay.
Um,
I found the people that,
that I work with through community.
Um,
and I think if you,
if you don't have someone in mind or you kind of,
you know,
having already started building that relationship,
that's also really good to be able to turn to other people who can vet them for
you in a sense.
Awesome.
Thanks for coming.
Um,
my question is,
a lot of times I hear women say like,
Oh,
I had no idea at that company was going to get this big or we are going to be
this successful.
Um,
do you feel it's important to go in with this like success,
vision or kind of just see how much your hard work can,
can yield?
Okay.
I mean for us I think what has worked best is thinking like a year ahead.
We still struggle to think three years ahead and I think that's just the nature
of who we are as entrepreneurs and like what sort of work we find satisfying.
And I think there are other people who it's really important to them to look and
say like in five years this is going to be a $3 million campaign in 10 years
it's going to be a $2 billion company.
I think you just have to know who you are,
know what drives you.
It's really hard for me to think that long term and be motivated by that.
But I can be motivated by what I think is going to happen like nine months from
now.
Um
Hm.
I,
for me where I am right now,
I think so much of,
of what I'm trying to figure out about,
you know,
my success and like how I should sort of even define that for my company,
um,
is there's a lot sort of coming at me based on the market,
you know,
a dollar shave club just sold for a billion and,
and so,
um,
right now and the law in all honesty,
I'm kind of a little bit and in the place of the question that,
you know,
you've asked and trying to figure out what's right for me,
what can I do as a business and,
um,
you know,
do I set a cap or not?
So,
you know,
I'm just going to be honest,
the question it always goes around.
Yeah.
I also think that people who say that they didn't realize it was gonna be that
big.
I also just,
I don't think you accidentally build like a billion dollar business.
Um,
so I don't know.
I think some people are just humble and they want to self present in a certain
way and maybe you know,
the market changed and they didn't realize that the opening was as big as it
was.
But I just don't know if you can accidentally build something massive.
Yeah.
I think also consider or give yourself room and your company,
whether it's a tiny company or a company with huge aspirations is give your self
room for those definitions to change.
Like I started my business with absolutely nothing in mind other than hoping I
could use that business to get a job at a magazine.
And I'd thought of it as like a step up to something different.
And then the market changed and magazines became unstable and web became more
stable.
And so my definition of what the business should be to change.
And then there are some years where I'm like,
my goal is to just stay afloat.
And there's some years where I have like really big plans and but like things
wax and wane and that's,
that's okay.
I think a lot of times businesses,
it's like linear thing and it's just,
it's totally not,
it's like full of all sorts of curves and turns.
Awesome.
Um,
I'm interested in the concept of the entrepreneurial spirit because I think
there's like an idea or myth,
but there's like the born entrepreneur,
um,
and obviously here within Google we work in kind of a hybrid environment where
we are within a huge multinational corporation,
but we also have a lot of freedom to kind of pursue things that interest us in
business opportunities that are available.
Um,
and so I'm interested in what kind of change for you where you said,
okay,
I'm not going to work within the structure of an existing business and sort of
change it from within.
I'm going to go out of my own.
So like you kind of touched on the fact that it was maybe market forces that
made you decide it wasn't a step up.
It was actually that was where you wanted to,
to pursue your career.
So I'd be interested in hearing your experiences.
My,
my experience has been that I think at my core as a human being,
I've always done,
I couldn't work for somebody else and be a very good,
I'm not a very good team player.
I'm just not.
I'm good at like creating teams and living like you go do stuff not good at
participating and that and I'm an only child you could play in that.
I don't know.
I just feel like I've always known I couldn't do that and my first two jobs out
of college were like very much team jobs and it,
for me it was a moment of like the biggest thing I'm taking away from this is
that I would never want to work for somebody else unless it was somebody that I
just absolutely thought like was the best of whatever they did.
And I would never question anything they did,
which I don't think exists.
So I'm just happier doing things on my own.
I also,
I think for me,
I the,
it's this idea of like realizing your own vision and like an idea that you've
come up with.
It's really just rewarding to me in a way that other projects aren't.
There's like something really special.
I think about that of like,
I can just think of so many conversations that like Eric and I had had in the
back of a cab or something that like six later real thing and the eight.
There's something so magical about that to me that that I think is harder to do
in a,
when you're working for someone else.
Um,
I would never say that I was a born entrepreneur and I don't think I had any
aspirations,
um,
until we came up with the idea for,
of a kind to start a business.
But I will say that I really loved that sense of ownership.
Um,
the Claire articulated and,
and always have.
And that's something that's always been fulfilling for me.
Um,
and beyond that,
I also trust that I am smart enough to learn things.
I don't know.
Um,
and I think that that's been the other half that has,
has been,
been able to push me forward and get me excited about things.
Um,
it'd be like,
totally,
I'm just going to dive into this and figure it out.
Um,
for me it's,
it's more about problem solving and I think that's where you actually find this
entrepreneurial spirit,
you know,
that you speak of.
Um,
it's to kind of say,
hey,
this is missing or this is being done really badly.
Or you know,
this is not really capitalizing on a great mark.
Like whatever those things are,
it's about seeing what's missing and this sort of desire to,
to figure out how to fill that void,
the white space.
Um,
that for me is,
is,
is where that spirit is and I think you can do it anywhere.
When I was at my,
my fulltime job recently,
I kind of always said,
you know,
if I had the opportunity to think I'm more the way that I really am,
I'm in this position,
I would probably have stayed longer.
Thank you.
Thanks.
Hi,
I'm,
my question is,
um,
kind of along those same lines I'm kind of interested in day one,
was your idea so clear and so right in your mind
[inaudible]
okay,
yes.
This is what I have to do,
like let's do it.
Or were there a couple of ideas and you picked the one that was most interesting
or like how did you go from idea to start?
Sorry.
Yeah,
we,
so Clara is applying for a job for us.
Claire was applying for a job at 20 by 200.
Um,
and she emailed me her cover letter and we were going back and forth.
I was sort of helping her edit her cover letter.
She was like obsessed with 20 by 200 at this point.
Um,
she was like,
I'll do anything there.
Um,
and in going back and forth and editing it,
we were talking about was so interesting about the business model and what was
so compelling about it and why it was needed in the world.
And I got off the train that night.
I'm going home and there was an email in my inbox,
it had read this instead of my cover letter.
And it was like,
what if we did this for fashion?
This doesn't exist,
but it seems like,
you know,
that's what our friends are consuming.
That's what we get really excited about.
And we fleshed this out over the course of like 20,
80 miles or something that I feel like I just got Chelsea about it again,
but not everybody's like that,
but like we did,
we,
it was like,
it was that idea.
It was like lightning,
but that idea I think,
you know,
is very much the thing that sits at the core of,
of a kind kindness,
this idea of limited edition pieces with a story.
Um,
but the thing that has spun out that,
um,
and I think the world we've been able to build around it was definitely not in
those emails.
Um,
and I think a lot of that has just come from what's been interesting to us.
The feedback we've gotten,
random things we've tried that have stock things,
we've tried that it failed and the business has been shaped by all of that.
Okay.
Um,
for me,
it honestly started with,
um,
uh,
need,
you know,
I,
the story is,
so I,
I went,
I called my girlfriends up,
you know,
to get like a pedicure and so on.
And I,
I grabbed my light pink razor and I scraped across my legs,
like I usually do and went out and I,
you know,
put my feet up on the basin and I will my jeans up.
And like the entire inside of my leg was covered with razor burn and you know,
we just started like batting back and forth about how freaking annoying shaving
was and so on.
And so I think there were like a few things that just kind of were percolating.
Um,
I had seen,
you know,
Harry's and dollar Shave Club at that point,
and I was like,
these mother still not doing anything for women.
I'm so annoyed.
I don't want to use your Dr. Carver butter or whatever the hell it's called.
Um,
and then it was,
it was just sort of,
it,
it just stuck with me.
I knew it was really strong.
It was different from anything that I had ever done before.
Um,
you know,
I'd had a lot of experience at that point and I knew that it was scalable.
Um,
and that was one thing that I wanted to be able to do.
I wanted to challenge myself to see what it would be like to build a scalable
business and to challenge the,
you know,
the,
the Gillettes and so on of the world.
And,
um,
yeah.
Then I grabbed my balls in my hand,
but yeah,
I,
it took a lot of gumption.
Yeah.
Cool.
Congrats.
Thank.
Thank you.
Thank you everybody for coming and being a part of this.
Thanks to Google for having us and thanks to postman for being here to sell
books and I hope you have a great rest of your day.
Thanks guys.
Thank you.